Ein Foto der Kanzlerin –
und noch ein paar hinterher.
Viele Tausend Bilder hat Laurence Chaperon
in den letzten 20 Jahren
von Angela Merkel gemacht.
Chaperon ist die bekannteste
Fotografin im politischen Berlin,
wird von Akteuren vieler Parteien
auch für offizielle Fotos gebucht.
Politiker brauchen auch Bilder
für ihren eigenen Zweck,
für den Zweck einer Botschaft,
was [die] ein Politiker rüberbringen muss.
Also, Fotografie für mich,
das ist Emotion und ästhetisch.
Und wenn diese beiden Faktoren
erreicht sind, das ist [ist das] ein gutes Bild.
Merkel mag, wie Chaperon sie sieht.
Viele ihrer bekanntesten Bilder
hat die Französin gemacht.
Darunter auch viele offizielle Porträts.
Ich mag dieses Foto hier sehr. Ich sehe
auch in dieses [diesem] Bild auch viel,
was ich persönlich gut finde. Und ich mag
diesen Zuhöraspekt in dieses [diesem] Bild.
1989 kommt Angela Merkel als
Quereinsteigerin in die Politik.
Die Naturwissenschaftlerin gilt schnell als
abwägend und nachdenklich.
Ich glaube, dieser Wunsch
nach kontrollierter Kommunikation
speist sich aus ihrem Politikstil,
der sozusagen Dinge vom Ende her denkt.
Wenn ich sozusagen mir überlege, wo will ich
denn hin, muss ich mir auch überlegen:
Wie will ich mit meiner Kommunikation
das denn erreichen?
Das spricht sozusagen gegen zu voreiliges,
zu schnelles Kommunizieren.
Am Anfang ihrer Karriere ist Angela Merkel
auch egal, wie sie aussieht.
Frisur und Kleidung passend für die Kameras
– so etwas interessiert sie nicht.
Das hat sie lernen müssen. Sie hat gelernt,
dass sozusagen kontrolliertes Auftreten,
auch reduziertes Auftreten,
sie stärker macht, sie auch unnahbarer,
aber auch seriöser macht.
Das hilft ihr 2006 [2007], als die internationale
Finanzkrise ganze Staaten bedroht,
auch Griechenland. Merkels strenger
europäischer Sparkurs
macht sie dort zum Feindbild der Presse.
In Deutschland ist
die Zustimmung umso größer.
Denn scheitert der Euro,
dann scheitert Europa.
Klare Haltung auch 2015: „Flüchtlingskrise“ –
die wohl größte Herausforderung Merkels.
Die Kanzlerin öffnet die Grenzen.
Ihre wichtigste Botschaft wird
schnell zum geflügelten Wort.
Wir haben so vieles geschafft,
wir schaffen das.
Wir schaffen das,
und wo uns etwas im Wege steht,
muss es überwunden werden.
Doch es läuft nicht alles nach Plan.
In Europa verweigern sich vor
allem osteuropäische Staaten
einem gemeinsamen Kurs in der
Flüchtlingsfrage. Und in Deutschland schüren
rechte Parteien die Angst vor anderen
Kulturen und bekommen mehr Zulauf.
Ich glaube, dass sie vor allen Dingen
Menschen überfordert hat
mit ihrem sehr reduzierten
Kommunikationsstil in der Flüchtlingskrise,
wo viele Menschen
nach einer anfänglichen Euphorie am Ende
dann doch sehr verunsichert waren
und sich nicht richtig mitgenommen fühlten
von der Kanzlerin.
Dazu kommt auch die Konkurrenz
durch die sozialen Medien.
Die Fotografin Laurence Chaperon
beobachtet,
dass die politische Kommunikation immer
schneller, aber auch schwieriger wird.
Einmal wegschauen, gern mit dem Kopf
Richtung Fenster ...
Manchmal, das kann ich verstehen,
dass auch bei der Politik …
die brauchen vielleicht [eine]
ein bisschen längere Erklärung
als auch diese kurze Botschaft.
Aber heute das ist [ist das] die Art
und die Kommunikation.
Und manchmal entstehen Botschaften
auch ungeplant.
Als Merkel 2017 beim Gespräch mit dem
russischen Präsidenten
genervt mit den Augen rollt,
wird das schnell zum Internethit.
Denn ihr Gesicht spricht auch
nach 16 Jahren Kanzlerschaft gern Bände.
Auch ein Internethit:
Merkel in altertümlicher Universitätskleidung
bei ihrem letzten Besuch in den USA.
Es sind wohl auch solche Momente,
die ihr persönliche Geständnisse zum Ende
ihrer Kanzlerschaft entlocken.
Wahrscheinlich werden mir
gewohnheitsmäßig verschiedene Gedanken
in den Kopf kommen,
was ich jetzt eigentlich machen müsste,
und dann wird mir ganz schnell einfallen,
dass das jetzt ’n anderer macht.
Und ich glaube,
das wird mir sehr gut gefallen.
Ich glaube,
dass die Menschen in diesem Land
diesen reduzierten Politikstil
und diese reduzierte Politikkommunikation
von Angela Merkel noch vermissen werden.
Alles um uns herum wird aufgeregter:
Social Media, die Medien ...
Alles wird reduzierter, wird knackiger.
Und Angela Merkel ist sozusagen
auch kommunikativ der Ruhepol.
Es nützt doch nix, wenn die Politik
genauso aufgeregt ist wie die Medien.
Laurence Chaperon
wird auch Merkels Nachfolger
noch oft fotografieren.
Der oder die wird sicher
viel darüber nachdenken,
was man anders machen könnte als die
Vorgängerin – und auch, was nicht.